good morning Hank it's Sunday November
1st the first day of NaNoWriMo in case
you don't know what NaNoWriMo is it's
National Novel Writing Month an annual
event in which people try to write a
50,000 word novel in a single month but
Hank before I talk about NaNoWriMo I
think I need to discuss something that's
been on all of our minds my puff it's
big Sarah pointed out the other day that
the puff has gotten so big that it's
kind of three puffs it's like baby puff
baby puff mommy puff so I apologize if
the puff distracts you so wait when we
first started brother-in 2.0 back in
2007 when home ownership seemed like a
good investment in you tube with square
all these nerdfighters started asking me
have you ever done NaNoWriMo and I was
like no everybody knows it's impossible
to write a good book in a month which by
the way is true wait what about on the
road yeah contrary to popular legend on
the road wasn't written in a month it
was written in seven years okay I was
wrong about on the road what about no
there is no such thing as a good novel
that gets written in a month because
hold on pretentious Mehcad let me finish
my point what about baby-sitters club
forty-three Claudia's sad goodbye oh
that is a great book seriously but it is
the exception that proves the rule
and as a rule no great book can be
written in a month that said I've always
really admired the nerdfighters who take
on the NaNoWriMo challenge and this year
I'm gonna join them there are two things
I really love about NaNoWriMo one
whether you're writing for fun or as
your job writing requires discipline and
it takes a lot of discipline to write
50,000 words in 30 days secondly I'm
increasingly convinced that while no
great book can be written in a month no
great book can be written in a first
draft no matter how long it takes you to
write it books are made in revision for
all three of my novels I have deleted
more than 90% of the first draft and
everything that people like about my
books emerges in later drafts like miles
is obsession with the last words of
famous people in Looking for Alaska came
out and revision they're crazy hunting
through rural Tennessee for a funeral
hog in an abundance of katherines
revision all that stuff about
cartography and the real meaning of
Paper Towns revision like if you want to
think about it like sculpture writing a
first draft is like digging the clay out
of the ground and the revision
is when you actually use the clay to
like build something that you like I am
a writer I come up with metaphors for a
living like that one see that was a good
example of first draft failure hey let's
edit that metaphor okay if you want to
make a chair your first draft is cutting
down the tree and then revision this
this is why my books take three years to
write what NaNoWriMo does for writers
young and old is give us permission to
suck so NaNoWriMo forces you to be
disciplined and it gives you permission
to suck which are two of the things you
most need if you're going to be a
novelist the other thing you need is an
adequate supply of snacks
I recommend Cub Scout popcorn so Hank
I'm seriously gonna try to write 50,000
words of a story over the next month I
will be updating you on my progress
every day at the Ning link in the
sidebar and to my fellow nerdfighters
who are joining me on the crazy
NaNoWriMo adventure there's a group
about it at the Ning and we also have an
official discussion forum over at the
NaNoWriMo website and no I am NOT going
to share with you what I write over the
course of November if I'm lucky it'll be
good enough that I can spend the next
two years revising it okay I should
probably start writing but Hank you'll
see me on Tuesday